[Music]
justice league
we are facing an existential threat to
the planet
our only option is to destroy darkseid
bow before me
a global war means everyone on the
planet is at risk
your gullible fools
dark side is playing you
the humans earned their facts
i know you hate me but i wouldn't be
here if it wasn't necessary
i'm completely on your side now
[Music]
no more planning just do it
we can't quit the justice league doesn't
quite
henshaw may be gone but this was still
the boldest move we've seen from
apocalypse yet
darkseid won't stay down for long and we
can't play defense forever
then we agree we're going to have to
take this fight to his doorstep
excellent
count me in team
[Music]
okay who left the front door open
welcome back everyone it's charlie this
is going to be my justice league dark
apocalypse war trailer there's a bunch
of easter eggs and i actually think that
they're borrowing from some of the
deleted
justice league sequels the live-action
justice league sequels when it used to
be a trilogy
some of this may actually seem familiar
if you know about a lot of the deleted
scenes from the original justice league
movies so i'll explain as we go along if
you're new to the channel
be sure to subscribe to get all the
easter egg videos we're doing a movie
ticket giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave your
favorite moment from the trailer on the
video
i know you're asking why is the title so
complicated why didn't they just call it
justice league dark side war
that'd be a badass title for a movie i
think the reason why they call it
justice league dark
apocalypse war is just to let you know
that it's a justice league justice
league dark
crossover movie because of all the
constantine stuff and he's a big main
character during the film
so if you're a big fan of that character
it sounds like he's going to be huge
during this next
dark side war style story as you see
from the pitch you basically have some
of the justice league turning evil it
sounds like that's an anti-life equation
in dark side just
mc's a bunch of the justice league
characters particularly batman like you
see i'm apologizing to damien wayne i
know i'm the last person you want to
trust
and of course damian wayne just sasses
him through the entire trailer
and here's the crazy thing if you guys
didn't see the slate of the title at the
end of the movie with the date and all
that stuff
it's actually a rated r movie that's
right a justice league rated r
movie if you ever thought that would
happen my guess is is they just go super
hardcore with it that's the only reason
why these animated movies wind up being
rated are
they did batman killing joke as a rated
r movie but that's obviously a
very very hardcore comic book story so
when you heard that they were doing
killing joke it was easier to understand
why they might make it rated r but
hearing that just a regular
typical bigger justice league movie is
rated r is a bit of a surprise
nowadays because the joker movie blew up
so big made over a billion dollars in
the dc black label seems like it's going
to be a thing in the live action
universe
now dc rated r movies don't seem so
weird
digging deeper into the easter eggs and
deleted scenes from the other justice
league movie it sounds like the pitch is
similar to the plot of the cancelled
justice league sequel
when justice league was still planned as
a trilogy of movies and i'm talking
about the live-action justice league
after all that stuff happened they came
out and they explained what the other
two
movies were supposed to be in that
planned trilogy so the second movie was
going to be their empire strikes back
with kind of a downer ending
with darkseid coming to earth at the
beginning of the movie destroying
everything
enslaving superman using the anti-life
equation after he killed
lois lane just to keep superman on team
darkseid
that was all supposed to play in to the
batman v superman nightmare sequence
that was supposed to be a vision of the
future that came to pass
in the second justice league movie all
that second movie
darkseid war stuff superman anti-life
equation was supposed to set up the
concept of the flash time travel scene
in batman v
superman during justice league three so
in that third movie
the flash was going to go back in time
with cyborg's help and batman
to warn batman in the past to save lois
lane
obviously we never saw any of that come
to pass there was this other plot line
where they had tried it before and they
were stuck in this time loop in the
first time that they tried to go back
into the past it didn't work which is
why all this terrible stuff happened
during justice league two
so when we get to justice league three
they try the other point in time to go
back to that winds up being successful
batman saves lois lane from dark side
superman never succumbs to the anti-life
equation and they're able to form
the full justice league with the help of
hal jordan
and the full green lantern corps who
would have shown up earlier in the
trilogy
most of that stuff never got filmed that
was just the story that they wrote that
they would have started shooting back in
2018 after that first justice league
movie came out kevin smith did this
whole long story about how he saw a
bunch of jim lee's concept art that's
right jim lee who's now like the sole
publisher of dc because of all the stuff
going on behind the scenes at dc comics
did all this stuff for the justice
league trilogy when it was still
supposed to be a trilogy
while they were making that first
justice league movie the studio
cancelled the trilogy plans turned it
into one movie which is the one we saw
in theaters so it sounds like the dc
animated people
love some of those story concepts and
decided to pick up on that and do their
own version of it as a rated r
movie like okay we'll do this dark side
coming to earth
taking over everything all hope is lost
some of the justice league get emceed by
the anti-life equation
then a bunch of the villains have to
work with the heroes and common cause to
save the earth and get rid of darkseid
like the reign of the superman
post-credits scene so if you haven't
watched dc
animated movies in a while there's sort
of a justice league line of continuity
with the superman
films in the last couple of years some
of the dc animated films are sort of
one-off and they stand on their own but
some of them are connected and that
includes the death of superman
reign of the superman and now this
sequel justice league
dark apocalypse war there was a reign of
the superman post credit scene where lex
luthor just
comes onto the justice league's
satellite and says hey team what's going
on
we're ready to defeat darkseid we know
he's coming obviously they're pissed
about it because this is just happening
now and he's been there villain for a
long time
but a while ago in the comics they did a
storyline called justice league dark
side war and
during that lex luthor also does work
with the justice league to try and save
everyone they take it in a bunch of
really twisty ways trying to use the lex
luthor character in a way that you
haven't seen him before
they play him a little bit more like an
anti-hero a little more complicated but
he still
really does not like superman one of the
great easter eggs you kind of notice in
the background here too though is alex
luther
does not do things out of the goodness
of his heart he's obviously using this
as an opportunity to turn public opinion
in his favor
he usually uses situations like this
particularly when justice league
characters go ham
on everyone else and they turn against
each other so that later when the
disaster's over and they win the day he
can go to the public
looking like a hero see i worked with
the justice league to get rid of
darkseid i'm so amazing now i'm such a
hero
elect me to public office then he can
pull a very spider-man far from home
post-credit scene style twist where he
shows everyone footage of justice league
characters doing evil things
under the control of darkseid although
he doesn't tell them about darkseid
controlling them with the anti-life
equation
you have to imagine a dc version of j
jonah jameson just shaking his fists
complaining about justice league
characters
trying to turn public opinion against
them that's a very classic
lex luthor style twist to pull and if
you're a big justice league dark fan
there's obviously a lot of justice
league dark stuff going on during this
with constantine going up against
darkseid trying to use his magic against
him
i really like this scene here where it
seems like he's trying to read flash's
mind
and seems like he sees a vision of
flashpoint like oh wow some stuff has
happened we don't know what's going on
the universe has already been rebooted
once but if you're big fan of justice
league dark it actually sounds like jj
abrams bad robot operation
is going to be working on some kind of
justice league dark movie but i don't
know who would direct that who they
would cast in it if they would use matt
ryan as their live-action version of
constantine it would be really cool if
they did that
crisis on infinite earths on the dc tv
shows kind of tried to bring
all that stuff together with the movie
stuff because of the big ezra miller
flash crossover with tv flash
probably one of the best moments from
crisis on infinite earth
but when it comes to the live action
movies i wouldn't hold your breath too
much about a lot of the tv characters
appearing in the live action movies
and speaking of dark side tom king said
that they're almost done writing the new
gods movie i believe there are a couple
drafts in they've been working on it for
a while now
the movie is based on his mr miracle run
which is amazing if you haven't read
that and you're really big fan of the
comics
do check it out tom king has been doing
some fantastic stuff
in related jack kirby stuff we're
talking about new gods dark side stuff
jack kirby over at marvel the very first
marvel eternals trailer is probably
going to drop in the next month or two
so of course i'll do videos for that
movie when we get it we find out what
it's actually going to look like
but everyone let me know in the comments
what do you think about them doing a
rated r
justice league animated movie it just
blows my mind that they would even try
that
the internet went a little crazy this
past week because of henry cavill
wolverine stuff
here's the video explaining what was
going on without what the reality is
and click here for that brand new
spider-man 3 announcement
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay awesome i'll see you guys tonight
[Music]
you